so I want to show you a very special
item here this right here to my left is
an authentic New York Yankees stadium
seat the house where Ruth Built and we
all know this logo here the New York
Yankees I just want you to think about
this I have to buy this because I'm
planning on giving this to one of our
top performers in our company and the
reason why I'm showing this to you is
because I just want you to think about
this stories behind the seat who sat in
this chair I mean this was there for 100
years 80 years 90 years how many fans
sat here and watched Babe Ruth hit a
home run or Mickey Mantle or Roger Maris
who knows what stories how much beer has
been spilled on this or hotdogs ketchup
or fights and disappointments and
ninth-inning full count homerun you lose
you win World Series it doesn't matter
what it is when I sum when I see this
this just came in today when I see this
to me it represents a lot of history but
if you're looking at this from the
business standpoint this to me
represents a brand that was backed up by
an entrepreneur CEO who was willing to
self promote this brand that is known as
the number one brand in the world this
is the most recognized sports brand in
the world because they know how to self
promote and by the way this brand has
2627 World Series championships in this
brand is worth if you wanted to buy 3.4
billion dollars you know why because an
entrepreneur knew how to promote this
brand way before anybody else thought of
the Yankees as the greatest sports
organization in Major League Baseball
some would even say any sport you think
about you think about the Yankees why am
i starting this video this way well
first of all I'm a big baseball guy and
and items like this fascinate me right
now I'm a negotiation with somebody
going say 1952 Mickey Mantle high graded
we're talking high numbers when
I talking $100,000 card we're talking of
a pretty expensive card I'm a fan of
sports teams like this who self promote
and I think you as an entrepreneur need
to figure out a way how to self promote
your business and today's video I'm
gonna explain it to in a way is that
especially to people who are because if
you're cocky and you're way way too
cocky maybe your approach needs to be
different on how to tie yourself promote
but I think this message is more for the
people who are uncomfortable on how to
self promote yourself and your business
and I'm going to tell you not only is it
costing you business not only is it
costing you profit it's hurting
everybody in your company if you
yourself don't figure out a proper way
of self promoting what you already
believe in whether it's yourself your
business your people your clients your
products your vendors your industry or
it doesn't matter someone behind this
brand new york yankees knew how to do it
so i'm a cover with you many different
examples and I'll give you do's and
dont's some things you can implement
right off the bat for you to start self
promoting so before I get into it before
I get into it I want you to see a number
here I got four names here to my left
these are four candidates that one of
them is going to be a president in the
next few days today is what today is a
we're a few days away from a press I
think by the time you watch this video
the video is going to be launched on the
election day this video is being
launched on election day by the time
this video is done with the first day
comes out we have a new president
America it's either going to be Trump
Clinton Johnson Stein so many people
I'll watch it you already know who the
president is
but this the point I want to make to you
here watch this number here watch this
number here if I ask you Joe Stein is I
am willing to bet 90% of you have no
idea Jill Stein is if I ask you who Gary
Johnson is I'm willing to bet 80% of you
have no idea who Jill Stein is if I was
to ask you do know the Hillary Clinton
or Trump is I am willing to bet 99.9999%
of you know who Clinton and Trump is do
you know why because these to know how
to self promote these two don't know how
to self promote it doesn't mean their
argument isn't strong it just means
they're terrible at self-promotion let
me give you some stats here for you to
be thinking about
Jill Stein has 261 thousand followers on
Twitter Jerry Johnson libertarian she
represents the Green Party you notice
it's green Gary Johnson's yellow
libertarian he's got three hundred and
ninety seven thousand followers on
Twitter she's got 10.1 million Trump's
got twelve point nine million Twitter
followers Brian wise he's by far the
best self promoter in the marketplace
obviously you see the Trump brand all
over the word like him or not there's a
lot to be learned from anybody because
on the complete opposite side here Ali
who Sports Illustrated said the greatest
athlete of the last century he said I'm
the greatest and he came out saying it
when he didn't believe it and then he
delivered and Henny became the greatest
ally right we just lost in this past
year you think about tbe the best ever
mayweather the money team I'm the best
ever I'm the best ever so many people
hate Mayweather
so many people love Mayweather the
reality is he never lost I'm not a
Mayweather fan many of you know if you
followed me but guess what the guy was
undefeated called himself the best ever
and I think that will last fight yet
with Pacquiao what was it 200
million-dollar belt how much money did
you make undef I think about that for a
moment here Jordan on this side the
greatest of all time prime time Deion
Sanders number 21 you know when he said
there's nobody I don't care what
position Denis was telling me if you
tell me any position quarterback
whatever there will never ever be a
better cornerback as good as me because
I'm the best ever number 21 you look at
more brands Cowboys four billion dollar
company the most expensive sports
franchise in the world is Cowboys then
you have Barcelona Real Madrid then you
have the Yankees here Nike
self-promotion Apple self-promotion
these are people who know how to promote
their brand and today they're learning
how to promote themselves so if you if
you yourself don't make a decision from
watching this video I don't sell promote
yourself on how to self promote your
brand I guarantee you you will be left
behind so let's go through a couple
different points here on thinking about
self promotions and how not to do it and
how to do by the way just think about it
for a moment here with even LeBron James
for longest time LeBron James didn't
want to answer what question what's the
question the question was hey are you
better than Michael Jordan you would
always say what he would say
oh you know Mike's the greatest of all
time why would you even ask the question
you know why would you even ask the
question and do you know what he started
saying this year what did he start
saying this year in an interview do you
know what he said I'm chasing the what
the ghost I'm chasing the ghost who is
the ghost Michael Jordan why because
Michael Jordan is the greatest of all
time and LeBron wants to say what guess
what I think I may be the greatest of
all time I've been to seven or eight and
he's only been a six yes he won six for
six but I never had a Pippen on a horse
grant he's making an argument I make
everybody else stronger Jordan was
himself all of those stats he's putting
up to sound the greatest of all time by
the way do I think he's going to be the
greatest of all time I don't think he
would be the greatest of all time we do
know what I do like I love the fact that
he said it finally he said it Kobe said
it he put himself on the line you got to
be able to have the audacity to say it
as well but there are certain things you
got to do before you say it so keep in
mind let's identify something before I
get into my 11 points what is the
difference between self promotion and
bullshitting what is the difference
between self promotion and bullshitting
self promotion can be backed up
bullshitters can't back up big
difference so a lot of the night a lot
of the introverts who don't like the
soft promote because they're like man I
don't want to come across as a
bullshitter if you know what you're
doing don't worry about it self promote
if you know how to deliver don't worry
about it and I'll give you a formula
today on how to do it so you're not
going to feel uncomfortable about how to
go out there and you know self promote
yourself you know this whole statement
that we hear about fake it till you make
it fake it till you make it fake you to
make it we hear it all the time or fake
it till you make it well yes fake it
till you make it but you better know
what the hell you're doing while you're
on the way of faking it till you make it
because if you don't know what you're
doing you're just fake period you just
fake period the whole act as if if you
can act as if but you better know what
you're doing while you're acting as if
there's got to be a part of you that
knows what you're doing so how do you
self promote yourself how do you self
promote yourself rule number one you got
to be shameless about self promoting
yourself you got to be shameless about
self promoting yourself
it'd be uncomfortable when yourself
promoting yourself you gotta be
shameless
I guarantee Dion shameless ali's
shameless mayweather shameless Stein
burner and Yankees he was one the recent
owners who passed away and pass it over
to his son
shameless Apple shameless nike phil
knight shameless cowboys jerry jones
shameless trump shameless clinton
shameless little bit shire but there's
still more shameless than the rest of
the people in the world you've got to be
shameless if you're not shameless no
one's gonna know who you aren't a part
of why we don't want to be shameless is
because we're embarrassed if we're
humiliated so what if you're humiliated
you know who's not humiliated do you
know who's not humiliated the people no
one knows anything about you tell me
what's more humiliating them what
happened with trump you tell me what's
more humiliating than what happened with
Clinton tell me you tell me what's more
humiliating when ally said I'm on a
knockout Frazier and Frazier knocked him
out you tell me what's more humiliating
than that you tell me what's more
humiliating than Michael Jordan when he
got the pass and the steal and Nick
Anderson from the past and he passes the
ball to Scottie Pippen and Scottie
Pippen in the interview when he makes
the comeback in the playoffs they lose
to Orlando Magic in the interview
Scottie says Jordans never given me the
ball I couldn't believe it he had to go
that entire season everyone's saying
Jordans losses it's [ __ ] you gotta be
shameless
you gotta be shameless there's got to be
a party that's got to be shameless
number one number two you tell your
victories through personal stories
let me explain for instance let's just
say you know you are an alumni from I
don't know from picker school Yale okay
and so you're sitting with a client and
said you know it's interesting I like
the fact that you are a Yankees fan
because one of my good friends who I
knew when I want to yell together
he was also big Yankees fan and I
remember when that thought that duh did
you see what just happened right there
now the client is saying about oh wow
you went to Yale but you didn't sail let
me show you my degree that I want to
yell you don't do it that way you
connect and you talk about what you did
right self-promotion here's another way
you know man this is an impressive
plaques I mean listen one things I can
tell you is for somebody like yourself
who I see
you're being recognized as a top
attorney it takes a lot of work to get
that you know because I respect that cuz
in our company when I got my plaque for
the top broker of our company I remember
the effort it took to get there and for
what's crazy is many times people don't
see the efforts behind closed doors so I
applaud you for what you did did you see
what just happened right there there's a
linkage of self-promotion okay there's a
linkage of self-promotion so there's a
way you do it I have a friend of mine
who's a doctor who has a hard time
talking about the fact that he's a
doctor this guy grew up in Inglewood and
everybody around them was either blood
crypt a prime time of colors is when
this guy grew up in that area he comes
out of that mess he goes to school gets
it gets becomes a doctor himself and he
doesn't want to say he's a doctor
because he feels like he's bragging
there's a way of doing it would each
skip it can be settled through stories
number two you're only as good as your
last victory so let me explain with that
what I mean by this if you're talking
about your victory from 28 years ago
you're Al Bundy and if you don't know
what Al Bundy is back in the days it
used to be a show on TV what was it
called it was called with married with
children married with children and a
main star his name is Al Bundy and he
would always talk about how he threw
four touchdowns in high school when they
won the championships and he was in his
50s okay and everyone said people who
talk about high school victories there
are Bundy's don't talk about victories
from 22 years ago you got to talk about
your most recent victories no one cares
about 16 years ago unless if you're a
grandpa you're telling your story to
your grandkids and I was 39 years ago if
you're in the hunt today building it
competing you got to talk about your
recent victories that you have number
three one of the ways you self promote
is you build up other people that's
strange because a lot of times people
think you self promote by knocking other
people then and there may be some
conflicting ideas you because some of
these people are experts at knocking the
other people down right you say hey Ali
used to say you look like a mummy he
looks like a mummy right when you hear
Ali talk all this smack he's the ugliest
man I've ever met in my life I've never
met a man uglier than him right he would
say all these types of stuff Mayweather
we try to do that Jordan was very big
when he was talking smack in the game
but there's an element of you building
other people up while you're building
your business I remember when we were
selling memberships at Bally Total
Fitness and I had just come to a new
club at Bally's and everybody there was
accustomed to selling the memberships by
bashing 24-hour fitness they would bash
24-hour Fitness and I told everybody
listen stop we're no longer bashing
24-hour fitness
they said why so let me explain to why
we're not going to bed sheers what we're
going to be doing so people would come
and I would say so let me ask you how
much you know about Bally Total Fitness
and what are the gyms are you looking at
oh you know what I've looked at you guys
in 24 Hour Fitness what do you like
about 24-hour fitness I like the fact
that 24 hour fitness doesn't have a
contract okay aside from that what else
is important is distance important to
you well yes
what's closer to your house a Bally
Total Fitness or 24-hour fitness they
would say where I live a block away from
Bally's I said so how far is 24-hour
Fitness from you nine miles how much of
a drive does it take in traffic about 30
minutes how long does it take to come
over here they would say five minutes I
said so that's about 25 minutes
difference going and coming back so it's
50 minutes right that's it it's 50
minutes times three times a week that
you planning on coming to the gym that's
150 minutes a week 600 minutes per month
is that worth more than $5 a month for
you and it would say well you know it it
is I said so you want to go to 24-hour
fitness and you're willing to give up
600 minutes per month just for five
dollars less just for no agreement it's
in time more important to than a price
on the down payment or memberships of
course it is I said because 24-hour
fitness is a great gym they have a lot
of great things going on but I will tell
you one thing about why people join
Bally Total Fitness here because we like
committed members because our members
who are close to us we're locating a
perfect location we intentionally chose
certain real estate properties because
we want to save time for you because we
want you to go home and spend time with
your kids and your wife that's important
to us but we still want you to stay in
shape does that make sense yes when we
got the contract the study come on board
and the contract isn't so built other
people have sometimes you got to ask
case so tell me about the competitors
what you like about them they do a lot
of great things let me tell you what we
do what's more important to you Tata
Tata and then you self promote your
business based on what the needs are of
the client out there number four make
some predictions
make some predictions okay
I predict that that is going to take
place okay for instance I just made a
prediction couple days ago on a Twitter
video and I told everybody what my
thoughts are on Twitter I may be
completely wrong but I feel based on the
research I've done and the intuition I
have I feel something going to happen
with Twitter and there's a reason why
their valuation went from being a forty
billion dollar company to today no one
even wants to pay them a ten billion
dollar company not Apple not Salesforce
not Google they all were interested on
one time no one wants to buy them so I
made my predictions about Twitter if you
haven't seen the video you can go see
the video the video's title is Twitter
the next myspace or something like that
let's put a link of it or video a image
of it so they can see it make some
predictions based on your intuition and
based on research why is that important
well what if some of your predictions
become a reality okay then you have
credibility because when you say what's
going to take place it becomes a reality
just make sure you're not making things
up based on no nonsense opinion then
you're like everybody else
you can't self promote that because then
your decisions are not that accurate now
some people may say what a dumb advice
fad are you really telling people to
make some predictions yeah that's kind
of what great real estate developers do
that's kind of what great real estate
investors do that's kind of what great
stockbrokers do they say I think this is
what's going to happen with the market
and if you want to position yourself i
forsee take in place so why not you do
it hey I foresee the economy and the
marketplace going dot that dot in this
area and I think you need to position
yourself here I think you're smart if
you do this I wrote a book called the
next perfect storm specifically for the
life insurance industry I'm not
recommending you read it it's for my
industry the life insurance industry I
wrote the book with the prediction I
made on what I foresee happening in the
marketplace the next 5 10 15 20 years
all these insurance companies read it
and they wanted to partner up with us
why because they said this makes sense
don't be afraid to make some predictions
within your industry your own
marketplace that you have gone out next
thing name-dropping let me talk about
name-dropping
there are ways you do name-dropping that
is absolutely annoying in it backfires
it's absolutely you know in a backfires
let me give you the simplest one
don't name drop if you don't know the
person okay so for instance if you say
something like oh you know what man I'm
good friends with Beyonce oh really oh
it's pretty impressive yeah you know
Beyonce night and all you ever did is
you went to a concert and Beyonce was
there with 30,000 other people
you claimed your friends because you're
friends with her on Facebook cuz you're
a fan you follow her on Twitter
Ted snap you're not friends right but
some people like to say that oh you know
you know I got to tell you about this
story with if you're going to name-drop
do it in a subtle way
but you better validate it people have
done that to me and once they couldn't
validate it it completely lost their
credibility one of the reasons why I
left the former company is because there
was somebody there that kept
name-dropping and they never became a
reality eventually everybody said this
guy's full of it
I like credibility I like for you to say
it and it becomes a reality show now if
you do name-drop for instance um yeah
you know John this is this is a great
opportunity to sit down with you and
talk to you you know one of the things I
like this you kind of remind me of Stein
burner back in the days I used to work
for the Yankees and when I work for the
Yankees I moved up in a company and I
started working with mr. Stein when I
travel up with he and his family and it
was a great experience but you and him
have a very similar presence together
and it's great to meet you I've heard a
lot of good things about you okay there
is a connection now if he goes back and
he finds that that never happened you
lose the deal but if he goes back and
finds that that happened man
credibility come on and what do we need
to do so you call back he's always going
to link you he no one's ever going to
say but you call back who's calling
Billy Bob or Billy Bob Stein Bernie guy
yes bring them in so now what if you
don't tell that story you wasted an
opportunity self-promote a good
opportunity here's another one - how to
drop it set a name drop book drop what's
book drop when you're talking and when
you're a very well reader if you're
well-read okay I've read quite a lot of
business books so if I'm sitting there
with a meeting and somebody says
something in a meeting and I'll see you
know what one of the books I read was
such-and-such and in this book it talks
about this and I feel like this is
what's going on here with the company
and I recommend that book to you on
you'll see them every time you'll see
someone if they're sharp they go what
was the books name again that that that
that that and yeah and you know what I
remember one time and another topic
comes up I read a book once called this
if you can give two to three book
recommendations in a business
conversation with somebody in their mind
they're linking you to a self-educated
autodidact you don't wait and you
constantly trying to feed information to
yourself because you're a self educated
person what do you have a degree or not
it's irrelevant in their mind you're
educated not they're not saying in their
mind you have a degree in their mind
they're saying you're educated you want
knowledge so book drops sometimes not
just name drop book drop sometimes next
strong opinions about certain subjects
within your field of expertise so it's
similar to what I said earlier on making
predictions but this is strong opinions
it's not necessarily predictions you're
making opinions I don't agree with where
the marketplace is going I think one of
the mistakes the industry made was that
I think they could have done this better
or they could have done this better this
even helps if you have your own blog or
your own vlog or your own podcast or
your own whatever you write where people
are seeing your thoughts in this you
know I wrote this one block about this
and I can send it to you they can read
it and in this blog it created a lot of
you know controversy because my belief
in it was you know such and such so for
instance for me four years ago I wrote
an article why I don't believe home
ownership home ownership is not the
American dream
this thing blew up a Fox contacted me
CNN contacted me everybody contact me
then then proposed that I think is a
number 15 publication in America they're
a feature on it and they sent me the
paper the frame is somewhere on you I
don't know where this is somewhere on
you if you go tap in Denver Post by
David and the whole feature was they
came pictures all this stuff this
entrepreneur doesn't believe in home
ownership that was my opinion it created
so much controversy just because I did
one video on YouTube saying why what the
real American Dream is and I said it's
not home ownership its entrepreneurship
right create a lot of debate share your
thoughts they say share your opinions
and self promote those articles that
you've written next have a certain level
of certainty on what you're talking
about people will know the difference
between certainty and somebody who is
not certain believe me it's not that
hard to know
somebody is certain about what they're
talking about you you initially when we
started doing channels people would say
Pat do you read a teleprompter do you
have a teleprompter that you go through
I don't have teleprompters I can't speak
about these things with you if it's not
fresh here because I can store these
episodes in my brain and remember
everything I'm telling you just like
people can tell if you know what you're
talking about with level of certainty if
you're feeding this thing and the more
with certainty you talk about your
certainty alone is a way of self
promoting yourself your level of
certainty is a level of self-promotion
that you're having next one too young
and new entrepreneurs a lot of times now
people will say well Pat how about if
I'm a young entrepreneur how do I self
promote myself if I don't have any
victories how about if I don't have
anything what am I going to self promote
myself when I'm dealing with some people
very simple everybody started off not
having anything to self promote
themselves with except for except for
the following mister mrs. Jones if
there's one thing I could tell you is I
don't know many people who are as
committed hard-working in their trade as
much as I am I can tell you this the
industry I'm going to make a lot of a
positive impact in people's lives I take
this thing very very seriously I take my
clients times very very seriously this
is why people like to amiss with me this
means a lot to me the fact that you open
your doors to me it means you trust me
to come into your us and present
different options to you that means a
lot to me and I don't take that for
granted that is very important to me so
I want you to know I'm very serious and
very dedicated about what I'm doing my
plans are in the next 10 years to open
up seven new office my plans in the next
ten years are to be able to take my
clients business from XYZ to ABC my
plans on the next five to ten years to
be able to do this and I'm hoping you
can be one of those clients I can do
this great work for with a lot of
discipline and dedication hopefully
you'll give me the opportunity to
deliver for you certainty commitments
where you're going you better deliver if
you don't you are not a self promoter
that's going places you're a bullshitter
you got it you got to deliver
you got it deliver if you keep changing
changing changing changing changing what
you're selling zero credibility this is
why I say choose one thing for 10 years
chew
one thing for 10 years and stick to it
for 10 years so now do's and don'ts
don't overdo it
it's annoying don'ts don't overdo it
it's annoying don't make things up I
already told you this let me explain
what I mean by don't overdo it
ladies think about it if you go on a
date with a guy who he constantly brags
about himself and 80% of the time he's
talking twenty percent of the time
you're talking that's you don't like
that who likes that no one likes that
right there isn't a single person that
likes well let me tell you who I am you
know oh yeah you know I know everybody
I'll go to that nightclub the bar cool
you know the owners know who I am every
time I like at the table they give me
the bottle you're annoying that's not
attractive that's annoying you're hiding
an insecurity there is something you are
not comfortable about yourself everyone
can tell everyone can tell then there's
the guy that just says oh great yeah no
problem awesome yeah but he still self
promotes himself here's why ladies i'ma
talk to you first and gentlemen I'm
gonna talk to you ladies honestly did
you really end up liking a guy who
didn't self-promote himself honestly
honestly are you dating a man that
somehow someway didn't self-promote
himself come on come on
you didn't self promote yourself what do
you think makeup is makeup is
self-promotion what do you think shaving
legs is what do you think of shaving our
goatee is what do you think us getting
our hair done that's self-promotion what
do you think it is - cologne
self-promotion what do you think it is
to work out self-promotion what do you
think it is to take care of our body
self-promotion how about you
self-promotion self-promotion when my
wife and I were they were dating
and we were we went through the process
of fighting it was after about you know
first six months everyone [ __ ] it's
not a real relationship it's fake the
first six months a fake it's Hollywood
it's not real don't believe it everyone
lies in the first six months I love you
so much whose dozen roses and a nine
months later what does it Rose this man
know I love you the toes are always
perfectly done every time like they get
their toes on every day eight months
later what happened there's cracks on
the toads what happened here
self-promotion is gone the reality sets
in all I didn't get a chance to get my
toes done and and they're kind of
walking arms up oh my gosh what happened
to those toes man there were nice toes
self-promotion has gone right a little
bit watch this stay with me here
my wife and I worked together for about
a year I haven't proposed yet and we get
into a very big fight you know what she
tells me whatever she tells me she says
don't you get it no woman is ever going
to treat you as good as I'm going to
treat you no one is no woman don't you
understand that she said this to me
watch when she said this to me she said
this to me and oh wait she's gonna watch
this on a video and she has no clue I
even said this I'm gonna show it because
she watches the video she has no idea I
said this that had an influence over me
proposing to her
think about that even my wife is a
self-promoter think about it so none of
us here are too good to be and it's not
it's righteous it's also stop the only
difference between you and some of these
other bigger guys did yourself promote
better than you and it work harder to be
able to deliver so my message is very
simple to hear go back watch this video
again take some notes make a decision
for yourself what type of a brand do you
want to build are you going to be a
brand like these guys that they build a
brand where a guy like me an
entrepreneur is willing to pay thousands
of dollars thousands of dollars just to
own a seat of the Yankees where Babe
Ruth built the house where Babe Ruth
built to give this away as a recognition
for what just because somebody know how
to self promote this brand and don't be
the entrepreneur that doesn't go and do
this because you will miss out on so
many opportunities if you don't self
promote yourself so let's get this you
if you got any questions thoughts
comment on the bottom and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel please do so
let me tell you something here about
this channel we have a lot of great
things will be launching here soon this
channel is going to be a million
subscriber channel our plan is to get
this two million and many many more
after that I don't believe there's a
single channel on YouTube that talks
about the subject of entrepreneurship
better than us yes I'm self promoting
but I dare you to challenge us against
anybody else no one there's a lot of
guys that keep saying the same rebuttal
same thing same thing same thing same
thing same thing same thing just in a
different way but there's no content no
substance I take your time seriously I
go a little bit longer my videos
because if I only go for two three
minutes it's just motivation I want to
give you value when you get off the
phone you take notes you implement and
you grow your business and I get the
messages of people telling me I was only
doing 80 grand last year my business is
not doing six million dollars per year I
was only doing three hundred thousand
dollars per year I'm not doing six
hundred and ninety three thousand
dollars per year those are the messages
I want to hear but this only happens if
you take this content and apply it so if
you haven't subscribed please do so
share this video with some of the people
that need to watch this as well and with
that being said then it's good catch
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye